this video is brought to you by - Lane
you hear on TV a lot that there is no
such thing as collusion sitting here
looking under federal code trying to
find collusion as a crime it's not
collusion is not a crime the Trump Tower
meeting was not a crime it was not
collusion collusion is not a crime and
it's true you can look through the
entire u.s. code and not find a single
crime called collusion and while that's
true that misses the point entirely that
isn't the end of the inquiry that is the
very beginning collusion is a shorthand
and what people mean when they use that
term is actually much much worse
[Music]
hey legal eagles welcome back to loss
planner where we explain the most
important legal concepts of the day
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
Bell for more legal explanations and of
course leave your comments in the form
of objections today we're talking about
collusion what is it
what is it not and what do people
actually mean when they refer to the
broad rubric of collusion what crimes
may fit under that umbrella now to
understand what collusion is I have to
give you a little background on the
nature of a criminal conspiracy and
accomplice liability because people
often use the terms conspiracy collusion
and aiding and abetting or accomplice
liability almost interchangeably they
are actually very different things and
have very different implications first
what is a conspiracy a conspiracy is an
agreement by two or more persons to
commit a criminal act that agreement can
be explicit or it can be implicit does
not actually have to be written down in
some sort of contract somewhere and
generally a conspiracy does not require
in overt act just an agreement to engage
in some sort of criminal act
unlike aiding and abetting which we'll
get to in just a second now what's
really important for the purposes of
this collusion discussion is that under
federal law a party to a conspiracy is
responsible for any criminal act
committed by a co-conspirator so long as
that act falls within the scope of the
conspiracy or is a foreseeable
consequence of that conspiracy so if you
enter into a criminal conspiracy you can
be held liable for any of the acts of
your co-conspirators regardless of
whether you did the thing in question
now a similar but different concept in
criminal law is called accomplice
liability commonly called aiding and
abetting aiding and abetting does not
require any kind of agreement only that
the accomplice commits or attempt to
commit some act with the intent of
furthering the primary crime and that
includes for example buying a gun and
giving it to a bank robber in
furtherance of a bank heist but it also
includes post-crime conduct like helping
the robber get away or hiding evidence
of the crime itself and sometimes even
offering encouragement counts as an act
in furtherance of the crime sufficient
to create a cop
liability even attempted aid even if
it's not successful is usually enough in
most jurisdictions to be guilty of the
primary crime but both conspiracy and
aiding and abetting require an
underlying crime you can't convict
someone of a conspiracy unless they
conspired to do something illegal and
you can't aid and abet something that is
totally legal but where there is
underlying criminal conduct generally
the conspirators and the accomplices are
as guilty as the person who pulls the
trigger itself so even if the members of
the Trump administration were not the
gunmen so to speak they can still be
held liable if they engaged in a
conspiracy to commit some sort of
criminal act or aided and abetted some
criminal act and acted in furtherance of
that but for liability to attach in the
context of collusion there still must be
an original illegal predicate act so
what could those predicate acts be well
based on public reports there's actually
a long list of things that may
potentially give rise to criminal
liability
the first is potentially aiding and
abetting or conspiracy to conduct
computer crimes this is generally
speaking all of the hacking related
activities there's a whole raft of
potential crimes under the Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act among others
including accessing private information
trespassing on computers and peddling
stolen data this could apply if anyone
actually helped the hackers break into
the Democratic National Committee or if
anyone helped out those hackers after
the deed was done that can qualify as
either conspiracy or aiding and abetting
Salutations hacker would you like to
disrupt democracy enjoy your stay in
addition all of these acts could qualify
as a conspiracy to defraud the United
States which reaches financial and
property loss through the use of a
scheme or artifice to defraud but it's
also designed and intended to protect
the integrity of the United States its
agencies programs and policies some of
what is alleged might qualify as bribery
of officials or in
Jools there may be a fair amount of
money laundering going on from foreign
governments or foreign officials there
are allegations that people who are not
allowed to bring money into the United
States may have done so through
intermediaries like the National Rifle
Association or through potential real
estate transactions where oversight is
minimal so if there was illegal money
funneled into the United States and
there was a failure to pay the correct
taxes on it which could give rise to
federal tax evasion claims but also
similarly state tax evasion claims
because the state governments tend to
tax exactly the same things that the
federal government taxes as well these
allegations might also give rise to a
conspiracy to commit election fraud
including illegal solicitation of
donations above federal limits
individuals and corporations paying more
than allowed under campaign finance laws
which is also a campaign finance
violation it appears that there is very
strong evidence of foreign influence on
the election through fraudulent news
stories and social media posts there may
be a conspiracy to engage in and
cover-up campaign finance violations
apart from just the monetary ones
including in-kind donations where the
president may have received something of
value that wasn't actual money like a
friend buying and killing potentially
harmful tabloid stories there could be
wire and mail fraud of course hiding in
plain sight may be the president's and
monuments violations by virtue of the
fact that he's operating a business that
receives millions of dollars in funds
from foreign nationals and foreign
governments there are the logan act and
fara claims on the basis that several
members of the Trump campaign engaged in
foreign influence peddling without
registering as a foreign agent then
there are the whole raft of crimes that
may have been conducted in conjunction
with the investigation into the original
crimes which include things like
obstruction of justice perjury making
false statements and witness tampering
which may be evidenced by President
Trump's own tweets where arguably he was
trying to influence intimidate or impede
witnesses who either have already given
testimony or will give testimony in the
Moller investigation and then on top of
that there is a potential RICO violation
I've handled a few RICO claims and I
usually tend to agree with Ken white at
Pope hat who says that it's never ever
RICO except that this is a possibility
for a RICO claim here we'll see how it
unfolds but Rico is incredibly
complicated and usually unnecessary
especially given the dozens of crimes
that we have already talked about which
may give rise to conspiracy or
accomplice liability so while it's true
that there is no such thing as the crime
of collusion what's actually out there
is much much worse now the u.s. election
infrastructure may be woefully
unprotected but at least you can be safe
from computer crimes thanks to dash
lanes identity theft protection dash
line protects your identity across the
internet by providing a tool to generate
strong passwords stores and auto fills
them securely everywhere across the
internet seamlessly through all of your
devices it's also a VPN which acts as an
intermediary to make sure that all of
your internet traffic is encrypted even
when you're on public Wi-Fi because the
Russians are out there or maybe it was
just a 400-pound hacker in bed try
dashlane for free for 30 days at the
link below and legal eagles will get 10%
off - Lane premium by using the code
below at checkout so click on the link
prevent hacks and protect your identity
from collusion with Russian hackers